it's very dangerous chuck because a lot
of what you're seeing
as attacks on me quite frankly are
attacks on science
because all of the things that i have
spoken about consistently from the very
beginning
have been fundamentally based on science
sometimes those things were
inconvenient truths for people and there
was pushback against me
so if you are trying to do you know get
at me
as a public health official and a
scientist you're really attacking not
only dr anthony fauci you're attacking
science
and anybody that looks at what's going
on
clearly sees that you have to be asleep
not to see that what an insult uh let's
bring in tucker carlson hopes to target
carlson tonight
he's got another special on the tuck
carlson originals but we got to get you
to comment on this i know you had this
uh tucker thanks for getting up hello
you have to be asleep if you don't
understand the criticism of him
is criticizing science
this is the perfect distillation of what
we just lived through for the past year
and a half
so here fauci imagines a couple of
things first of all he refers to himself
in the third person which is revealing
it is bizarre second he imagines that
sincere questions are the same as
criticism
he imagines that questioning science is
attacking science
science is not a book that you check out
of the library or look up on wikipedia
science is a way of thinking and it
begins with deep skepticism about what
we think we know
you commit science when you take nothing
for granted when you ask hard questions
we think this works how do we know that
it works that's what science is
so here is a guy who represents science
who imagines
that questions are an attack on science
i mean he's instantly disqualified
himself as a scientist
in addition to revealing that he's got
weird louis xiv
tendencies i am science no you're not
you're a federal bureaucrat
answer the question do masks work tell
us the truth how do you know they work
where's the study that's that is science
those questions
we commit more science on a talk show on
cable news that he does
it's incredible